Hawaii's erupting Mauna Loa volcano may
be now threatening a main road the
world's largest active volcano continues
to blast a lot of hundreds of feet into
the air on the state's big island and
it's showing no signs of stopping
Jonathan Vigliotti is near Mount Aloha
with the latest Jonathan good morning
and good morning to you the pace of this
lava is slowing down quite a bit as it
reaches flatter terrain geologists
though say they have detected what
they're calling a large number of
Tremors around the eruption sites which
means at least for now this lava will
continue to flow
foreign
continues her Fury two active events are
shooting Fountains of lava into the air
and feeding glowing rivers of molten
rock down the Mountainside I've waited
my my whole life to see this the rare
event caused thousands of Spectators to
jam-pack the DKI Highway which became an
impromptu viewing Point what's going on
in your head as you're watching this
club
um just new New Birth New Beginnings but
it's also creating a worrisome scenario
for officials thousands of residents and
visitors that are flocking to the DKI
and the eruption site to view this
current monologue eruption uh creating a
safety hazard
although the flow is slow moving it's
still persistent and emergency managers
are ramping up their planning as it
threatens to cross over this same
highway it's very high probability that
this lava flow if it continues will
definitely reach the road so we're
looking at about two days out but
despite the risk Mount Aloha poses it's
a unique chance to see how nature
creates new land
and it's still unclear how much longer
this lava will continue to flow
scientists say it could be a few days
even a few weeks for now this once in a
generation event is more of an
attraction than it is a threat
hmm sure is beautiful but it's also very
scary thank you very much Jonathan